here we go we got C-SPAN pulled up right
here ladies and gentlemen as you are
tuning into this segment what can you
see motion to adjourn Republicans 219
Democrats 212 one Republican voted no
but it looks like the yeas have it and
our lazy members of Congress who did
nothing but sit there all day are voting
to go home without getting the job done
well I guess to be fair even those Brave
We the People votes of the Republican
party like Matt Gates Lauren bobert
Biggs Etc Cloud I think cloud as well a
lot of people there's like 20 people 20
21 they're also voting to go home so
fine fine whatever I suppose if it means
more gridlock and nothing's happening I
guess the argument is uh it's a good
thing you know I don't know Luke seems
to be pretty it's a great thing it's
it's a beautiful thing because the
longer Congress fights with itself the
less they could fight against the
American people and you know 11 times
rookie numbers 1856 took 133 rounds of
voting over two months to elect
Nathaniel P Banks as Speaker of the
House again let's try to beat those
numbers here we're not far away we got
to keep pushing at it and I think the
longer Congress just gets in battle with
itself the more beautiful it is for
everyone else the more freedom we have
the more Liberty we have the less
government we have which is overall good
I want to get this article up real quick
McCarthy nominated for 11th ballot in
the longest house speaker contest in 164
years loses again it feels so good I
think that the longer it takes uh how
did you phrase it the longer it takes
the better off we are yeah it kind of
kind of exists until there's a
diminishing return because if it happens
for say seven years then yes yes thank
you you're speaking my love language in
the southern border the cartels already
are running uh the the government
especially in Mexico and they're
connected to the intelligence agencies
and if you look out how the cartels got
their start they wouldn't be as violent
and as prolific if it wasn't for
American government and and the Mexican
Government running protection records
for them and giving them a lot of money
as nice as it is to you know fantasize
like oh what if the government didn't
work for two years the next time it's
time for Ukraine to get their check so
we can do money laundering for everybody
that works for Northrop government in
Congress you know takes money from them
the next time they want to cut a check
to Ukraine the Democrats and Republicans
will do a deal so I'm enjoying this time
it's a lot of fun but we have to
acknowledge the Democrats and the
Republicans they're on the same side of
every major issue you and they all want
the money at the end of the day that's
why I'm wondering did you think there's
any value to it if it keeps being
gridlocked and they keep they can't
figure it out at some point should it go
to a general election like we're voting
for our president we're voting for our
speaker it doesn't have to be a congress
person it probably shouldn't be a
congressperson to some American that
wants to step up and run and do the job
it could be anybody uh they've
officially adjourned they're all going
home
they're going to come back on January
6th and I wonder what tomorrow is going
to be like January 6th huh yeah January
6th it's a historic day that's like
that's like Democrats 9 11. is it yeah I
think some I think some uh you know
Windows got broken that day right right
a guy with horns walked around I think a
police officer shot an innocent woman
too yeah that's true I don't know yeah
shot and killed her January 6. it's so
far this is the one story that just
shows how split the country is if you're
on the left some of these people said
things like January 6 is the new Pearl
Harbor oh yeah that's how crazy they are
worse than 9 11. but then on the right
you have people saying this is the new
July 4th like we're gonna celebrate
we're going to have a good time that's
that's that's also very dumb I mean I
think if people want to celebrate it I
roll my eyes at it the people who are
saying it's like Pearl Harbor that's
like oh come on yeah for real I can get
why people are like there were people
cheering for January 6 but I'm like you
guys you gotta understand
it's one thing when people stand defiant
and like like this Matt Gates is like
we're blocking Kevin McCarthy this is a
tangible political conflict it's like
what I mean to say is there's actually
repercussions for what's happening right
now January 6 like nothing happened
Windows got broken people got people got
hurt Trump Sports got hurt there was no
political gain it actually just
benefited the machine that's why I'm
like that the whole thing was dumb one
of the things that nobody's talking
about is the pipe bombs on January 5th
you know the FBI discovered these pipe
bombs that were planted on January 5th
and right now Jacob wool is putting out
information that the government is
interested in like wait okay fine you're
investigating the story so we're going
to look into it too as to where these
pipe bombs actually came from they're
finally looking into it thanks to
Independent journalists like Jacob wall
and it's just amazing how many people
are still locked up in a gulag in DC for
what for going on a self-guided tour the
government let them in they wave them in
the videos are there them waving them in
let's let's make I I like the Nuance a
lot of people walked around they walked
in from the back entrance where the cops
wave them in and open the door and
because of this there was a direct
acquittal I think more than one there
was a direct acquittal of a guy in all
charges because there's a video showing
the cops waving him in another guy got
charges dropped but was still charged
for other reasons they were because like
he still ended up doing something that
was criminal but the trespass was like
no the cops did wave them in what
happens is people the staunch people on
the right side all the cops let them in
well there were there were people
fighting on one side smashing into cops
and fighting their way on on the other
side the cops opened the door both
things happened you know like the riot
was bad the violence was bad but most of
the people who were walking around they
had the doors open for them the people
who were fighting with cops were blocked
and struggled to get in it's also
interesting to see that the FBI a couple
days ago announced that they're going to
be doubling the reward money for
information that's going to lead to the
arrest of the pipe bomber uh that of
course laid the these pipe bombs on
January 5th very strange that this guy's
not caught here there's a lot of
involvement with the intelligence agents
here's here that of course it's still
being kept away from the general public
but in the new 1.7 trillion dollar uh
Omnibus Bill that was just passed there
was a provision there that's going to
double the doj funding when it comes to
Prosecuting people for January 6th and
it looks like they're going to try to
arrest double the amount of people that
they already have for the events that of
course happen on that particular day so
it looks like this is something that's
not going to be ending very soon I think
we need the tapes released I think this
is also one of the things that's being
negotiated right now with Kevin McCarthy
as even Tucker Carlson on Fox News came
out a couple days ago and said hey if
Kevin McCarthy releases the January 6
tapes then people will back him and
support him and vote him for speaker of
the house this is what according to
Tucker Carlson is being debated right
now at the house and is one of the key
Provisions behind keeping Uh Kevin
McCarthy in that position of power what
takes the January six tapes of exactly
what happened there and then all the
information that came forward there's
still a lot of surveillance footage that
is being kept away from the general
public there's a lot of videos there's a
lot of evidence still that the American
people have not seen that would probably
paint a a picture of of what happened
there in more detail than what we
already know I ran a poll in the chat is
it funny that McCarthy lost 11 times 95
yes I voted yes yes it is funny it's
funny it's funny strange Maybe funny
funny ha ha I don't like these people uh
Luke makes a really good point there's
there's countless hours of evidence from
January 6th that actually I'll I'll
throw it back to Ian's point the other
day that when you hit the nail on that
with the hammer saying sometimes no
investigation is better than
investigation because if McCarthy does a
sham investigation with a limited budget
it will convince people that that was a
real investigation they'll say look we
investigated all that stuff we found
nothing it's like you found nothing
because you gave him 10 grand like you
need a speaker who's going to go in and
say we're going to get a legitimate
hearing a legitimate commission with
real money behind this otherwise you get
McCarthy and I I think you were right
when you said that I think you want
independent commissions looking into it
too however who's going to appoint the
independent commission who are they who
is their father who's their second
cousin who are the who's paying them you
know I don't know but the idea that the
government would investigate itself
always makes I mean they have before
let's let's have some Nuance here
because I I agree in your in your
sentiment and and probably said that
their exact words before but when it
came to the church commissions we found
out a lot that we would have never found
out if it wasn't for uh you know Brave
members of of Congress coming forward
and saying hey let's really look at what
the intelligence agencies are doing here
and then we found out a lot of their
bigger secrets and a lot of how they
were manipulating the corporate media
when it came to the consensus of our
society so I I I'm I'm on the other side
here I want more investigations I want
the government investigating itself I
want the government fighting itself I
want the government spending time
looking at each other rather than
looking at the American people uh on
average Congress passes about 85 bills
in a year hopefully we could stop that
number and make sure that they pass less
bills with this deadlock and one could
only dream right guys what do you know
about the lead up to the church
commission are you familiar with how
they got that going no I I do not I just
know that it was it was uh eye-opening
commission investigation and and
Congressional hearings that were
absolutely game changing when it came to
actually seeing what was happening
inside of the United States and just how
far and just how unaccountable some of
these intelligence agencies have gone
straight away from their original
purposes of fighting uh actual evil it
looks like it was called The Church
committee was like the the general term
but it was really called the United
States Senate select committee to study
governmental operations with respect to
intelligence activities was the actual
committee's name uh started in 1975 and
investigated the CIA and NSA what else I
actually wrote about it in my book
what'd you write about well just the
fact that they have people embedded
across the news media like the New York
Times Time Magazine all of these
different institutions admittedly had
CIA operatives embedded within them so
when you're watching corporate media if
you're not watching something
independent you're basically watching
the CIA giving talking points to people
that just repeat whatever they tell them
let me let me tell you how it works
you get 20 something out of college
journalists they're making a garbage
salary for a digital rag
when all of a sudden they get this big
story
CIA Source says Donald Trump bad man
and then everyone sees this small story
all these other outlets New York Times
Atlantic Etc Washington Post and they're
like whoa whoa whoa is this legit they
reach out to the editors and they're
like yup we have a legitimate Source
we've vetted this and this is a huge
story
this now young person is getting their
names set everywhere how do they get the
source and intelligence agencies how do
they get this all that information more
stories come out more stories come out
eventually companies come and say you
got good sources man come work for us
we'll give you double the salary then
they start getting mentioned then they
start getting asked to come on TV now
they're on TV saying our sources and the
intelligence agencies are saying these
things and they're like wow
because the intelligence agencies select
someone
feed them stories because they know a
young desperate journalist will run
whatever they say because it'll build
their career for them let's call what it
is grooming the CIA
become journalists yes that's a 20 right
there that's one way that they're doing
it uh in other ways they just have you
know see how many employees also work as
the editors and decide what story gets
published and doesn't get published and
uh yeah I mean both ways are true and
um I think it was uh what was his name
oofket a famous German journalist that
actually blew the whistle about how the
intelligence agencies were coming to him
with free written stories that he
literally just had to put his name on he
also uh died suddenly of a heart attack
a couple years ago as well what was his
full name I think you remember everybody
I literally have that in my book too I
was looking for it yes yes
award-winning famous German German
mainstream corporate journalist just
came out and said hey most of my top
stories weren't even written by me they
were written by the intelligence
agencies and I just put my name on free
money and no work wow you find the right
person who's got no Scruples and deal
and no soul have you guys ever discussed
on this show where the origin of the
term fake news comes from uh yes it
comes from a think tank that uh Eric
Schmidt financed with Hillary Clinton uh
uh during the 2016 presidential election
the first Washington I actually
confronted Eric Schmidt on this I was
like Eric Schmidt you were a part and
and fundraised money for this Tink tank
that originally created this term and
then weaponized it against your
political opposition when you were
working and campaigning for with Hillary
Clinton and he told me some very bad
words uh you can still see that video on
YouTube for something I told you some
bad words he said some bad words what
were you saying the first Washington
Post story that dropped the term fake
news before Trump then took that term
and stuck it right on CNN and all the
actual fake news amazing the first story
on the in the Washington Post calling
people fake news it was talking about we
are change and about 100 different other
media Outlets we are the origins of fake
news my friend well they used it against
us I know they weaponized it you should
clarify that statement oh excuse me yeah
that sounds a little bad out of context
yeah but them trying to come after us
and label us with what they are which is
what they always do yeah like accuse
your enemies of what you were doing they
put out the fake news so they want to
call Independent journalists legitimate
people they want to call us fake news so
the origin of that term is them trying
to vilify us demonize us thank God Trump
took that term and stuck it right on
that it's very much the modern
conspiracy theory term the term
conspiracy theories invented from what
I've heard by the CIA to make people
that were saying that Kennedy was killed
by more than just Oswald there was
something they were saying there is a
conspiracy out there to say no you're
just a conspiracy theorist you're just
theorizing about conspiracies when in
fact they were conspiring at least
allegedly it just came out the CIA was
involved according to Carlson he had
some evidence I didn't see the episode
but uh Tucker actually I got I gotta
give a shout out sucker because I got
the sweet Tucker Carlson says dan
Crenshaw is a committed neo-liberal he's
a tool of of his donors he's hawkish on
Ukraine's border but indifferent to ours
and Dan Crenshaw knows that Kevin
McCarthy is the least conservative
speaker he is likely to get ever and by
the way he did call people terrorists I
listen to the video yeah it could be
taken out of context because if you
listen we should maybe listen to that
clip if you guys have it um but he said
he can't let the terror you can't let
the terrorists what he was doing was it
was like that was the Mantra that he was
repeating like a military Doctrine like
you don't you don't negotiate with
terrorists kind of thing he just like
plugged in a mantra so it was kind of
like he wasn't it saying there they are
literal terrorists but he used that
Doctrine so you could see how people
will think he is Fox News called them
insurrectionists did you did you see the
Fox News anchors they were literally
saying the people not voting for Kevin
McCarthy insurrectionist thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
on next time